[Music]
his name was Mungo his name was Mungo
it's it's something that I have to eat
at Christmas oh no that's Mofongo fungus
Mungo Jerry Who's born in England right
he's near it but so Mungo is is a name
I've never heard of a person named Mungo
outside what you don't know there's
three guys in comedy named Mungo yeah
Mongol Morel no Mungo Sam's real name is
[__] yeah
[__] Stavros [__] Gillis you know
[__] [__] is not a good Mungo is a
word that they look like though Shane
looks like a [__] yeah
big [__] yeah
um don't be gay dude I mean that's a
terrible name [__] yeah I don't love
mango what your parents are doing to you
have to name you Mungo but let's be
honest well why is his last name Jerry
Jerry because I
don't know no he's like real nasty
the name of the band no yeah
I mean well I don't know
pimp I just cursed bleep it
bleep it sorry yeah bleep it sorry it's
funny because
like more work the name Mungo is a boy's
name of Scottish origin meaning my pet
Michael that's what [__] means
a bit Scottish nah dude I look Irish
don't do that to me that's so
disrespectful what's the difference it's
like me being to you being the go you
look Egyptian no you're not no you're
not no the only way you can disrespect
me said I look Dominican you do you look
Puerto Rican Egyptian or Dominican with
the glasses yeah the glasses goes on
that those come with an ethnic ethnic uh
on the tone I wear them now once every
two weeks is what I'm doing once every
14 I throw these on I didn't like them
when you got them but now I do you like
because I was going I I I you've grown
on me like a pervert Yeah
you know you know what I was walking
today you know what I'm I don't want if
you're a man
you know what I don't want to hear a man
say oh there's so many things but you
know what I really I heard a guy on the
phone saying and a guy was on the phone
I don't know if he's yelling at his wife
whatever and he goes how dare you yeah
as a man don't say how dare you you know
what's worse no it's only maybe worse
than that well I never I never it's like
be a guy is it okay to be a guy how
about this I don't like when I hear a
guy say ow
yeah ow I saw a guy he went ow don't you
cannot say ouch
is what a kid says a kid goes ouch but
adults say ow ah no ah is fine ah it's
fine [__] oh that's okay no but I always
say that's look listen say it again ow
yeah gross yeah grow up you know it's
like a guy it doesn't hurt you know it
doesn't hurt now if you're saying ow it
doesn't hurt it doesn't hurt so stop so
stop faking it if it hurts you go
yeah here's here's how I know I don't
care if you have cauliflower ear and
you're like a 10-time UFC winner if I'm
walking past you and you go how dare you
I never ow I can beat the [__] out of
you
I know I can I can can you imagine like
I just hope you're walking down the
street one day and you hear that and
turn around it's Jon Jones
position no
do you um yeah I I don't know why he
real the guy really annoyed me I'm
starting to get really now annoyed at
like just the pussification of what a
man is is now this is what happens in
the summer
if in the sun you start getting I just
got like I I you know I used to do a bit
about this but I really do mean this I
really do think you know guys just men
like you like go how it is in nature
like if you're bothering me with saying
things like how dare you went out if I
just want to shove you a little bit and
then if you want to show me back we can
get into a little who's dominant here
you know what I'm trying to say his tea
is really high right now I just want to
hit his high tea lately that's what's
going on when I put the glasses on the
tea gets high in the summer for you
because a lot of vitamin DT right now
they said it's 690. that's pretty good
that's good naturally well you're
working out you're slimming down you're
bulking up dark glasses on you got the
glasses on you're still young what you
know what I've been trying to do lately
is not worry about so much calories in
calories out of the fasting but try to
get 210 grams of protein a day it's
almost impossible to do you have to
drink so much and eat so much that too
much protein is not good for you that's
right well 210 but you should get your
grams your body weight in grams I I
gotta tell you something to build muscle
so you mean like the whale guy that
played the whale running 40 grams of
protein yeah on my 1200 pound life they
had to have 1200 grams of protein to be
healthy yeah that's all you need
sometimes is 1200 grams of protein you
don't you don't need to eat that much
you're doing fine I told you yesterday
how good you look you wore those same
stretches little pants I know these are
my pants these are my built everyday
pants
2.0lt uh what's the code hey babe no we
have no code for them this is this is
organic built t-shirt and build pants
this is organic promo because I just
love it stop plugging them something
right now well because I'm not I'm
trying I'm doing because I like it so
I'm doing the good deal a real man
doesn't plug I like that a real man butt
plugs that's true
look how much protein per day is too
much
eating more than two grams per kilogram
of protein for a long time lost they
lost me just kilograms they lost me too
many numbers that's it as soon as you're
like you should have this many if you
start adding kg mm I know I don't even
know Gram I don't want to hear kilogram
I don't want to hear kilometer we're in
the United States that's right give me
pounds yep and give me miles how about
two grams per kilogram or something who
what am I what are you talking am I the
guy who Am I who am I the guy that knows
like uh yeah
smart black guy who like like
him well my Neil de grams Tyson
that's why everyone's like you know what
you do it's portion control you just
weigh it you just weigh your food
yeah well I don't know how to weigh that
well then you buy a scale well I put on
a scale but I still don't know all these
extra shits yeah these conversions if I
got it could do any type of conversion
just count me out just don't even count
me in what happened this morning I had I
I lost
something having a day the amount of
times you said Who Am I who Am I who am
I
you were sifting through the uh what
happened this morning yeah take us
through your morning I know something
happened I can feel it you know why
because when I came in and I kissed you
on the cheek it was different than it
usually is yeah something happened
because normally kisses you on the lips
that's right it's funny that you say
that you're the second person to tell me
today that I I see him off and
something's wrong something I was going
to say it too but I didn't I I was
thinking something might have been wrong
so I didn't want to say anything I
understand when you walked in something
but now that it's out in the open and we
are we do have the cameras rolling let's
tell us well let us let us at least
monetize and exploit it
maybe this will get Rocket money back
let's do a plea to Rocket money rocket
money
rocket money you've been with us for
years we use you personally a lot of
times we don't necessarily use the
products we use you they just canceled
all nine of our ads out of nowhere not
even a warning just cancel them all like
a company
I made a phone call yeah nah this is bad
guys I mean who do you think who do you
think is in the president of Rocket
money right here this hello
[Music]
it's everything tell me you stubbed your
toe in the shower and you went ow and
then I did that and then it went back
you know when I when I burn myself in
the shower for some reason since I'm a
young kid I yell the same thing where'd
it go I yelled nice
one of two things and I and I it's
ingrained and I have I have no choice in
the matter okay I go yeah
I swear to God I yell yeah sir every
time I get burnt in the shower since I'm
about since I'm about 12 I've yelled
yeah
do you look when you get in the shower
huh do you look in the curtain first to
make sure no one's there it's just out
of habit of course I'm still here well I
don't know yeah I don't have a curtain
that's
human beings that are my human curtain I
have a human curtain nice you said cumin
cumin curtain well they are all they are
a little spicy Andrew cumin yeah
I don't have a cur I don't have shower
curtains sometimes I have clear glass
doors on one of the bathrooms and the
other one is a two bathrooms three and
the other one is you see in La you get
some more bang for your buck and the
other one's a walk-in I I you know what
it was because after we went to so many
hotels we when we redid our bathroom
because the house we the house sorry
three bathrooms in there are we done oh
yeah the house that we bought was a dump
a dump like we bought a dump so we
wanted to put money into it and after
all these years I was like I hate
stepping into a shower I love hotels
that you walk in I don't like stepping
up and into a shower I like oh like the
tub just a flat you don't want to step
over the tub yeah I don't want any lip
at all I don't like lip no lip right
don't give me any lips especially my
wife no lip that's what I said I sat on
my lip from the shower from you yeah
and so we designed it like a so it's a
long glass uh wall and then you walk
around and so none of the water comes
out it's it's I like you're for the
water I don't like that wait I love the
I built the wall in my own home yes and
you know who built it for me yeah say it
money rocket money a bunch of humans
bought it yeah wait you have to kind of
shower where there's no door you just
kind of walk in and then like it's open
air hate it so dumb why I don't like why
oh my God now you sound like you set out
to that drafty
[Laughter]
no that's not draft there's no draft
there is no draft but there is well
there and there should be another draft
sign up today otherwise we're drafting
you yeah because World War Three is
coming it's coming whose side are you on
the good guys or the Russians oh yeah
dude it's not drafty yesterday you come
over to the house it's a double rain
shower with the wall things too you are
encased in water so I have to say when
you stop it no no no the trouble is at
the end too and you wrap up before you
even get out
when there's a half glass wall That's
clear and the other half is open what do
you have a glass it feels too exposed
wife to see no no no no no no no
you want to be hidden away no no no I
like a coziness to a shower not like an
open grandness I'll say this I don't
like stepping over the tub either yeah
but I don't know what do you mean open
Grant it's just it's just it's a rain
shower from this and then the wall has
the the wall once I've seen shouts I've
been in so many so what do you like I've
been in one just like yours what kind of
channel do you like I'm Sebastian what
kind of shower do you are you in Paris
aren't you embarrassed about the shower
you like you like to be a college you
said carumba in the shower
[Music]
I've been to Andrew's house many times I
that's why I frequently uh sleep over
yeah because I save money on a hotel and
I stay in Andrew's guest room and I've
been in that shower and it is very
comfortable and all the only thing is
and yeah he has like these little things
that move in the wall though that's the
only thing that was weird yeah like
every time I move something goes it
follows you yeah I don't know what that
was I don't know yeah I thought it was
like a jet or something but it's not a
camera or anything no there is a camera
but it's only motion censoring it's not
ah okay we don't have the tape or
anything you just want you just it's
just there it goes away at the end of
the day actually live streaming on my
patreon go to Andrew Santino's
patreon.com look who's in my shower.com
it would be fun if I had a show where
it's just comedian friends coming over
to shower
don't even just cut it here so you just
see them yeah no there's no nudity it's
just hilarious because you know what
take away the nudity the F we all look
so funny in a shower you look so dumb
because you're Spacey you're not paying
attention you're thinking about a bunch
of stuff you and and the way that you
could have been so funny you're probably
singing stupid songs the way I feel
myself look sometimes like you know if
I'm going over like a joke or a concept
in my head in the shower and I can feel
myself going yeah
yeah yeah
I see how dumb I probably
believe somebody that's not there
fight about about somebody you want to
really talk to that like pissed you off
during the day and you say it to
yourself and you're like come say that
to my face [__] you know what I say you
know what my little is and I've done
this before my little fantasy that like
a Dubai Prince
um comes up to me and I will do his
action in the shower he'll be like I'll
give you 100 million to come entertain
my people but you cannot live until I
say you leave and I do this negotiating
seriously I'm like you're gonna send a
jet he's like
I really play Both Sides in the shower
often I want to be swept away to Dubai
by a prince I don't know I think it's
fantasy fun I want to be like stolen as
a comedian and go somewhere and they're
like you must entertained for unknown
amount of time we get cheeks that watch
this really yeah hit me up cheeks cheeks
well listen the thing is though I want
to go to Dubai that's all I want a baby
and we watched ourselves if we didn't
know we've been recording just just for
your own eyes you see yourself in your
own home yeah taking a shower doing when
you're not paying attention we're
probably so mortified for other people
to see us oh my God you know what I mean
because you look so ugly and it's just
whatever you're doing saying when you're
walking around if you're new to it wet
you is so gross everyone wet gosh so
gross you look so sad with your hair
bangs down in your in your eye and your
body looks so gross when it's wet for
some reason I don't know what that is
soap suds everywhere this looks stupid
yeah you got water in your face
every time I towel off there's always a
booger somewhere on the towel because I
in the shower and every time there's one
stop by the way you don't you don't in
the shower no really no do you pee in
the shower I have I pee every time me
too I exclusively pee in the shop
it's not like I don't I don't do it like
I do it but the moment I step in IP yeah
same with me sometimes I cannot be first
no if I have to pee and I'm gonna shower
I wait I sometimes I hold it until I
need to get in just because I like it it
feels good to have water on you when
water is coming out a lot of times when
I'm having trouble peeing or I'm peeing
too much peeing in the shower kind of
resets me
my stepson's hilarious because like you
know I've made jokes like ah you can pee
in the pool who cares like everybody
does it anyway don't worry and I went
outside and he was standing outside of
the pool peeing
I swear to God and I was like holy holy
crap and I was like no no you can't do
that he was like I just had to pee so
bad but why see if you said it's okay to
be underwater why is it not okay to be
above water oh I get it I get it yeah
he's right yeah it's a salt water you're
playing mind games my two-year-old why
wouldn't he just turn and just pee not
in the pool why so why don't you just
jumping and peeing in the pool
he said the water was too he had turned
pee on the grass no because it is does
feel good peeing in the water it doesn't
sound into a pool that way
someone's never been to Hollywood
from outside from standing outside I've
never seen it before you've done that
yeah
cut it out
yeah I had a guy for my 30th birthday we
rented a house on the Hills it just
reminded me you're 30. I'm 40. oh happy
belated thanks no uh we had a guy for my
30th birthday this kid Josh I'll never
forget the pool was a it was a beautiful
house in the Hollywood Hills and we
rented a house by the way this guy
[__] sucked he complained the whole
time he constantly was complaining about
uh ogun Nicole from The Neighbors I was
like you know we rented this for a party
you knew it was it's isolated enough
where we wouldn't bother there is no
houses around yeah he was just lying he
just want to call he just wanted to keep
tabs to see what was going on and anyway
the house overhung the pool like it
overhang and it was a big big pool and
this kid Joshua that's so funny I don't
know why I did that Josh uh my buddy
Josh M yeah Josh do you want to say Josh
Josh McCoo Josh got on the roof and he
was like gonna jump in the pool and was
was wasted and I was like don't don't do
that yeah cerebral spinal action and
then he goes okay oh no I mean you
couldn't miss you really couldn't miss
the pool and he was like okay okay on
the way up he almost fell and I was like
get off the roof like he almost fell on
get out there and he jumps and he Clips
his leg on the side of the pool and all
the downward force made him go belly
first face first and I mean bruised
bright red his balls were bruised his we
his penis was bruised for like a week
because he slapped so hard so all this
was screwed up he's lucky he didn't
knock his teeth out and and break his
face so then the guy calling to keep
tabs he's not out of line really because
you were I didn't jumping off the roof I
didn't I wasn't doing it Josh did he
break his leg I don't think so I think
it just I mean honestly I don't know I
never talked to him ever again do you
ever see that guy I don't know where he
is I never spoke to him ever again did
you ever see uh you know Blake Anderson
yeah sure he broke his back uh jumping
off the roof at a party he broke his
back did he he jumped recently no it was
like a few years ago it's online too
dude yeah
of it he's had a huge party he jumps off
the [__] roof and breaks his back how
but but it was it was this for a bit
shout out to Blake Anderson
he'll be on uh the next uh season he'll
be on Joker's season 10 when it starts
up I didn't get an invite he's in DS I
didn't get an invite to be on Jokers
would you like to yeah not now I mean I
don't want to bet on how to beg for it
you know you should have considered me
at some point
people that work with you in it right
now
offer it to me it's not like it's not
just my choice
know those other guys
whoa oh wait
oh cause he jumped onto a tank he tried
to do the thing that they do in uh
wrestling no
what city is that where they jump on uh
uh buffalo buffalo yeah You Gotta Love
The Comedy Central branding right
the company that doesn't exist anymore
that's why after this they got suited
they really not exist at all anymore or
pretty much they exist but they don't
right they don't have new shows they
they uh
they they buy syndicated shows I don't
think they make any new shows I don't
think so yeah I don't think anyone's
making any new shows right now right now
because the writers are like give us the
money give us the money and it's like
okay yeah there's a writer strike going
on so no no there's not
birth control hello
oh you are all right we're coming right
out what food did you get we're coming
right out Papi
okay he's come my guy's coming right out
he's big he's known as a bear
who knows oh they know each other he's
right there he's three feet away what
did you order he's known as a baby what
did I get let's see
smoothie is that a smoothie yeah a
protein shake
I'm trying to get I'm trying to get my
grams and then we got
what is it that looks like pasta chicken
it's chicken broccoli uh peppers and uh
Buffalo well I said buffalo sauce but I
think I put a little come on there
be careful you don't drip that oh drip
you know what's day drip you stay drip
dude that's funny that you said that
right I thought of that and I thought
did you see a pooling though you just
have the same kind of brain I have some
of your brain I have some of the OCD not
as bad as you but I have some of it you
made me flip over my money that's a
weird yeah what was that well the the
points
were facing me I just I'm not getting
into it but that's I just can't have
points like you see you're strong if
your straw is facing me I'd ask you to
kindly politely turn it the other way
otherwise I'd literally get a tension
headache and I and I won't know what to
do with myself anyway you look tan by
the way so you know I was saying you got
a good color I was out in the sun
I rented a little house for the week
last week and I up and oh and Mom Song
yeah I had I had a uh
that's also constantly the name of my
Jamaican talk show that I'm going to
start Montauk
Montana did you have that in the chamber
no that's good you're a big summer guy
you're single I love it you're fun you
like you're a fun and the sun kind of
guy sometimes Andrew's a fun in the sun
kind of guy and I avoid the sunlight
but you enjoy what number SPH SPF SPF
That's how little you know about it
SPD SBD SVD SVU no no who those girls
that sang
this is where voices that's right I love
SWV really I use I use 30.
I guess sun protection
but actually anymore now because of my
schnoz is always out in the sun because
I golf a lot I use zinc now zinc with no
chemicals no nothing it's so you want to
use zinc everywhere
McGregor the Clive Owens yeah the actor
I think what you're trying to say is uh
uh Clive Davis yes but he's just a old
producer what happened Andrew Tom Brady
dead that's so silly for you it's a
thing that they do on the internet now
and I wanted to see him that's so silly
have you seen that on Tick Tock people
go up to their parents with like people
their parents love it's so funny
together
so mad they get mad at the news so they
yell at the person that gave it to them
Google Google Rosanna Scotto Dead prank
it's one of the most New York funny
hilarious things yeah this one this one
look at this this what you mean right
Andrew look look at all New York this
woman is yeah the parents lose their
mind huh turn it off
yeah
64. no 64. we'll go eat at a family's
restaurant
with her
[Music]
the kid's crying
I'm joking
the kid knows don't play around
wow I mean does Rosanna Scotto know this
exists yeah because she has to I mean
that's and it's some one of those things
when I saw that I was like these could
easily be my neighbors dude Tick Tock
compilation Duran Duran Duran Duran yeah
that's okay but this is what I maybe I'm
but it's just like yeah Celebrity Death
Tick Tock right like this is the new
thing now oh no [__] oh my God Bruce
Springsteen dead at 73.
oh
that sucks what what happened Donald
Trump dead at 76.
oh heart attack shut up
shut up
oh my gosh
oh my God Randy Jackson dead
Randy Jackson
glasses
[Laughter]
how is that not a perfect Eminem fan
it's all real you can't stage that we
would know right away
it's crazy how mad people get like when
they hear that news I I hate when I if
it spreads like wildfires it doesn't get
me if I hear it I go nah it sucks but I
would never be like oh no
I never freak out about set not mad they
were mad some of these people are might
really get you upset who would really
get you upset if they died yeah upset
yeah not sad sad wait wait what's the
difference make the distinction sad sad
I to me is like you take on a Feeling
yeah upset is like disappointed yes
disappointment and upset are kind of
parallel who would make me sad if they
died
a celebrity yeah I don't know not a lot
of them oh I don't know I don't know I'm
trying to think of who would be Houston
if she died yeah that would be bummer
Yeah well yeah stay off the internet I
don't know who would make you sad
um honestly sad I was super sad when Ray
Charles died for real he's dead yeah I
was super sad when Don Rickles died yeah
it was a two Echo recall I just think if
they're old and they Woody Allen if they
die young
that would break up I've just started
watching USB when he dies I'll be saying
Just For the First Time started watching
Woody Allen movies me and uh Jazz watch
one video you know what made me sad
night yeah we were watching One a night
each night so far we've got six nights
in a five nights in a row you have not
yes we have you have you're telling me
and you're looking at me through those
glasses yeah telling me that you've
watched five Woody Allen movies over
five nights since we fall asleep you
know and then we watch them we wake up
early we've been doing a thing in our
house you watch him in the morning we
watch them before the kids we want Cafe
Society Blue Jasmine Wonder Wheel match
point and now we're and now we're on um
uh uh rainy day in New York City or
rainy night in New York City with
Timothy chalamet we're watching oh
you're watching new johns yeah I'm not I
can't get into an old movie if it's
before the 70s I even like good ones I
don't I just you can't watch like Annie
Hall no I can't watch a black and white
movie or something with it I know it's
from the 60s and 70s it just bothers me
he needs color yeah well you can watch
not enough diversity of an all-white
movie not a black and white yeah but
I've been watching Woody Allen movies
Woody Allen movies and they're all uh
they're all they all have an ending that
you know they leave it up to you which I
hate and like at the same time there's
no there's no finality you can't do this
movie he does it in every movie I've
seen so far besides match point
that's where it was Scarlett Johansson
tennis something Scarlet Joe and the guy
from Bend It Like Beckham
Jonathan Rhys Meyers I don't know who
that is Jonathan Rhys Witherspoon a lot
of people have three names I don't like
it Joey Lauren Adams John Wayne John
William Scott
yeah
third rocks from the Sun who's that uh
uh uh I see him Mary Tyler Moore Evan
Rachel Wood and Rachel Wood yeah I see
who's the guy from third reference
R.L Stein JK Rowling
no
yeah wait wait wait so who's the guy
from from the Sun
I always forget his name Barack Hussein
Obama
there you go Joe Budden Joseph Gordon of
Gordon-Levitt jgl from angels in the in
the Outfield is where I know him from
JBL
Angels in the Outfield was a good movie
um did you see did you see uh that uh
John Paul Jones Oakland A's are going to
be moving uh Las Vegas good sell the
team we need a team back in Montreal too
I would like to see a team back in
Montana no why Baseball American the
exposed I think I don't even think the
Blue Jays the Xbox don't exist no I
think the Blue Jays should not come back
for 19 years more than that 29 years
yeah what do you mean oh my God no no 2
000 and something two thousand
it was in the 2000s oh sorry 2004 sorry
right so 19 years now 19 years wow so
you were right the first time well
because I said 1994. so I'm I messed it
up yeah it was two thousand wow that's
crazy I thought they were still but I
think the Blue Jays should come we
should we should have a team in Puerto
Rico well that I mean we don't have any
major sports
get a tax rate yeah the Yankees that's
the Yankees you have them they're here
we're the porter oh yeah yeah they're
the Cubs yeah Hawaii has no teams you're
going to Hawaii
don't have any teams they shouldn't have
any sports teams have you been to Hawaii
yeah oh yeah you're out there so it's
Hawaii it's like a joke yeah it's a
quick trip it's me it's like you going
to Montauk right right yeah yeah what is
Hello fresh it's America's number one
meal okay that's right with hellofresh
you get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep skip
trips to the grocery store and count
them hella fresh to make home cooking
easy fun and affordable that's why it's
America's number one meal kit yep and if
you're stuck in a recipe rut take a bite
out of something new with 40 recipes to
choose from weekly with options to
please even the pickiest eaters You'll
Always Find meals everyone at the table
will enjoy that music to my ears because
my kids don't like to eat no matter what
your lifestyle you always find delicious
recipes at the hello Fresh menu even
though pescetarians and new veggie
people okay yeah you can swap out
proteins and all that other Jazz uh
I you know we've used it we've used it
on we've filmed ourselves using it we
cooked at your house yes well I love
hella fresh I it's something that my
family uses truly weekly so here you go
go to hellofresh.com hey babe16 and use
the code hey babe one six for 16 free
meals plus free shipping uh again that's
hellofresh.com hey babe16 and use the
code hey babe16 for 16 free meals plus
free shipping uh hellofresh America's
number one meal babe guess what I got a
brand new hour of stand-up material I'm
gonna be doing the special in Atlanta in
December those tickets are on sale soon
but come see it before I film it we got
the Borgata in August we got Radio City
sold out in New York so we added the
theater at MSG September 23rd still some
tickets available for that we've
announced Irvine California Portland
Seattle Las Vegas Omaha Nebraska Kansas
City Missouri St Louis Missouri Hammond
Indiana Pittsburgh Detroit Columbus New
Haven Connecticut Providence Salt Lake
City we're coming to you baby with more
being added soon christycomedy.com for
Ticky Wiki's I hope you guys are going
to really like this hour I think it's my
best work come see it we have a good
time in the front row if you buy tickets
for the front row I'll give you a kiss
on the lips and a bag of my pubes
hello guys and I just want to give you
some dates right now the very last
weekend of the Joker's tour for now the
first leg is happening July 27th uh 28th
and 29th we're at Nashville at the Grand
Ole Opry Cambridge field house uh in
Indianapolis and the stifle theater for
two shows on the 29th in St Louis those
are available at
impracticaljokerslive.com come the New
Year we will be adding the second leg of
this tour so if you didn't see us yet
don't fret uh other than that the reason
we are shifting is because I am going
back on the second leg of my solo tour
and I am filming a special in December
at the Vic Theater in Chicago Chicago
and Chicago's surrounding greater
metropolitan area I chose you come out
and support your boy
um leading up to that I will be at the
Hartford Funny Bone in August I will be
at the Syracuse Funny Bone in September
I will be at the there was another Funny
Bone in there and I don't remember uh
Albany the Albany Funny Bone in August
as well and then we're doing Bowling
Green Kentucky Cincinnati Ohio Toledo uh
Wilkes bar bear I never know guys I'm
sorry in Pennsylvania Wilmington
Delaware uh maccon Georgia Savannah
Georgia Athens Georgia Peoria Illinois
Rockford Illinois Cedar Rapids Iowa
Springfield Illinois and then I'm doing
a very special one-night warm-up show
right before the special in Elkhart
Indiana at the Lerner Theater those
tickets if not yet are going to be on
sale very soon at savocano comedy.com
pay attention to my socials because I'm
going to Tweet all the pre-sale stuff to
get the best tickets first uh that's
pretty much it check out my merch and
check out the podcast merch go to
samplecanocomedy.com uh Jokers are
starting up again season 10 the second
half of that Thursday nights at 10 on
TBS and True TV I love you I will see
you on the road I'm very excited
I've never been there I've never been to
Hawaii great man they don't like you
down there but why because you're a
Howley what's a howling white guy
they don't like Hollies really why is
that we're in charge because you know I
never heard of a hat where did that come
from what's the etymology uh look it up
look up how look up Holly and then I
want to talk about the Titans
we've talked about this Titanic story
too I I read a quick headline the other
day that white guy sometimes you
sometimes you just barely always use
this brand if you call you a Howley
right to your face no because that's not
that they call you a lot of other things
right but I mean but they don't like you
but what but why not too long so
Hawaiian term for individuals who are
not native Hawaiian and is applied to
people primarily of European entry but
okay well I don't like pineapples the
original word uh James Cook quarter
several at a time generally giving
European distinct more distinct terms
what's the etymology there it is down go
down three names Robert Louis Stevenson
offered 100 to anyone that could uh
three names Dr Theodore Richards
uh without without husk or wife uh I
don't know don't you hate when you look
something up and you read and you can't
get to the bottom I don't know explain
it and you go well I don't even
understand this oh that's what it is
without breath yes I have heard this
without breath without breath meaning
we're like soulless like we don't we
don't care about the earth and the
environment no it stands up top yeah
yeah
a lot of the a lot of the Hawaiian
native uh uh uh ideology is to uh take
care of the earth more than you take
care of anything else I take care of the
earth I use paper straws
and I gotta I got a chargeable car I
don't think they're big fans listen I
take my tourist money elsewhere yeah and
it's like you know the whole thing is
tourist trappy so like their whole lives
are surrounded by tourists coming in
being like
in your opinion like where do the
natives go because I'm sure you you
you're you're the Andrew's the type of
traveler very similar to you so you're
not gonna go where the tourists go oh
you'll do it once you find the other
spots
Kauai I think is the best Kawhi Leonard
is the best Kawhi liners
I think I think how funny was that laugh
remember that this is so funny we pull
up the Kawhi Leonard laugh and then I
want to watch this guy let's pull up how
you spell I think Kawaii is probably the
best one to go to here it is Kawaii all
right Kawaii I'm a pretty fun guy
um
I'm a fun guy uh obviously I love the
game of basketball
um
I mean it's just more questions you have
to ask me in order for me to tell you
about myself I just can't give you a
whole spill
I don't even know where he's sitting at
[Music]
dude it's like a serial killer
yeah
it's like a series
[Laughter]
[Music]
so much about basketball but not about
how to be in person you know Kawhi
Leonard's one of these guys you know
that signed a big contract and then
drove the same car from 1997 Ford
Expedition for like the first 10 years I
absolutely love him he was he was worth
about he was worth about close to 50 to
60 million dollars driving the same 97 I
don't like this game I don't I don't
like this game I think it's a cornball
game I don't like it I don't like people
do this thing we're like you know get
off the heck is drove with Subaru Legacy
yeah but he lives in a 40 million dollar
house so shut up I don't like that game
he still stays humble dude you're like
no he does he's flying private jets to
Paris
but he's driving his the car you know
why people do this with the car thing is
because some people just don't care
about cars so I hate when someone goes
he's super rich and he still drives and
then it's because they don't even like
cars that's like that just those that
thing that people do I hate it Warren
Buffett Warren Buffett always lives in
the same house he bought in 1990 1955
which is true it is but he has six other
homes right which they never tell you
yeah I swear to God yeah and he barely
stays at the one in Omaha right he just
has it because he's had it yeah it's
also huge and beautiful
like old historic Midwest house it's
stunning yeah that's the one that he
kept yeah that's the one he kept it's a
beautiful home it's not like you know
it's not like a it's a thousand square
foot mom and pop one bed one bath no
it's a beautiful home it's not like it's
not like Kanye's childhood home right
exactly right right like and that like
when they say it they make it sound like
oh it's so humble you're like yeah
that's not that's nice that's not it
right well I'm gonna see it because
speaking Omaha I'll be there October
18th La Vista Nebraska that's a real
place Vista it's called La Vista
Nebraska right outside of Omaha I think
it's called the Astro I like it yeah
I've never been in Nebraska one state
I've never been to and I'm gonna try to
go see the capital capital Lincoln it
would be a nice Capital check off the
list I got a few more capitals to go
check off the list what about Montana no
I never been North or South Dakota nope
no one's always yeah no you've been any
of these states I've been to almost all
those I've been to one of the decoders
I've been to Montana once and Lincoln
once but the other places like you if
you're not going to hit on the tour
you're not going to see him like like uh
Mount Rushmore that's where you could go
if you're gonna go South Dakota yeah why
did you go to the Dakotas or or Montana
Rushmore comedy Montana multiple times
back in the day when I first started
used to do a thing called a triple run
which was Triple run was uh these small
shows that if you were a nobody
headliner it's like a d room you didn't
get you a couple hundred bucks you'd
have to drive up there with the friends
right we do Idaho Nevada all the way up
to Montana from L.A you would drive up
there yeah man what is it like 10 hours
uh hold on one second yes
Mount Rushmore is that similar to like
the Alamo where like like when you see a
picture of you like wow look at this but
then when you're there it's like there's
a Starbucks at the foot of it no
opposite it's on oh yes there is a
Starbucks at the foot of it but when you
see it you're stunned when I saw it when
you say but there is a star but like
it's like when you see the picture you
just see the the faces but then when you
go there not right just like there's a
Walmart no no down the way down the way
there's like where you can get drinks
and snacks and all this [__] but when
you're isolated looking at it no it's
it's I don't know it's a must see I
don't know a lot about it it's the same
way about the Grand Canyon I've been in
the Grand Canyon no the Grand Canyon to
me is escapes me dude every time go go
once yeah I ca it's Indescribable what
it is is you'll go and physically be
looking at it and your brain will trick
you and be like this is a painting
people fall a lot or they jump a lot uh
there for multitude of reasons but one
of them they think there's a psychology
behind it it doesn't look real it looks
so big it looks out of this world almost
like you're on another what is it like
just like a large I don't know you feel
very overwhelmed by it it's like it you
know what I'm saying pimp it's like
you've been there pimp yeah it kind of
It kind of shocks you yes it shocks your
call you can't believe you fix your
breath it's that big you almost again
I'm saying there's a psychology you can
read about it people think it's not real
like they some people go to the edge and
slip because they can't the perception
of a stupid person that's a dumb guy
because even if they think oh that's a
painting they know it's not but no but
it's not that there is something that
happens to your brain that when you see
it you kind of just can't believe it the
you cannot fathom something so long was
it that an asteroid hit Grand Canyon how
did it form I think Trump's uh when the
first time that Trump ran he did it I
think he made it biggest hole I'll make
the biggest hole
no it was I think it was a natural break
from it was erosion well I think it
first started as an earthquake and then
it was erosion and then but we I've
hiked all the way down I did the hike
you can do two you can do a halfway hike
or you can do an overnight hike you can
hike all the way down to the water you
can sleep over and then you did that you
slept over in the Grand Canyon oh yeah
holy smokes none of your business hey
what's his name I did it with my college
girlfriend at the time and there's two
ways to go down you could take a donkey
you can literally get on a donkey which
is lazy paisy Daisy or you can do a
backpack hike with a guide and you sit
and you have lunch halfway can you die
though like is it possible you can die
of course you can yeah
it's not like climbing Mount Everest
no no dude no I mean like that anybody
can do this the point is you have to be
hydrated and eat and stop some people
also your your D your descent and your
Ascension has to be
um timed so if you go up or down too
fast yeah it'll make you scuba diving
yeah how deep is the canyon I don't I
don't want to miss schools
look she's getting a little chubby big
deal
you see it all at one one clip or is it
like I'm looking at one side that's the
other you can go to different rims they
call you you're right the south rim the
real job you know and I knew you were
gonna do that and I didn't like it
that's why I talked to Sal for a second
because I knew you were gonna do
something now you're being mean you're a
nasty look is this where James Franco
cut his arm off yeah it is 127 feet deep
or something 127 Hours and I just didn't
do it no I actually think that was in
Utah for some reason I think that was in
but that could happen to you your arm
could come off there no no chance if
you're getting between rocks not too
many people you can't hike alone out
there what kind of animals we got over
there
snakes coyotes mountain lions uh Bears
mountain lions yeah in the canyon yeah
yeah Canyon lines but and then don't say
that to their face they'll get pissed
off well that's what they don't like
that they're trying to fight against
that well because in this day and age
you know what I mean yeah things are
different
question though uh yeah look at how
beautiful what does your tour guide do
if you come upon a canyon lion
you know he he's got a gun
yeah I want you to talk to me seriously
now no they have a gun
he's gonna he's gonna gun down a
mountain lion and put fire a shot out
into the air it would scare them away
you hit somebody climbing down no chance
you shoot away the Canyon's massive and
that's going to take care of every
Canyon right there mountain lion no big
they've spoken to each other like listen
they just shoot it in the air but here's
the deal I love for these guys will
communicate to the other guys but they
think it's they're like I still don't
believe I don't know they still haven't
figured it out Evolution wise they're
still gonna know what the scientific
name is
did you see anything
uh to be honest no I think I think you
know what it is I think there's too much
foot traffic
the snakes everywhere poisonous snakes
but what about when you're sleeping oh
what about when you Stitch the 10th for
real
uh no they do it for you oh yeah they're
down there they're set there's camps set
up do you know what I mean yeah it's a
whole tourist thing yeah I went you went
with 30 people we did it was groups of
you know it's like groups of I think we
were like 30 or 40 people in our other
travesties down there oh sure you know
it usually happens some people get
halfway down and they bail they go back
up because it's too they don't want to
do it they realize it's so far dude at 6
000 feet no it's not yeah how many hours
he gets a thousand feet deep yeah
brother how how many feet is a mile
yeah correct so how long does it take
you to get down Andrew would you say
52.80 yeah I get down all the time how
long would you it's true Get down on it
take a second if I hit my song look out
what did it take us it takes you like a
full day because again you do stop and
counts like when I'm saying a full day I
mean like
I think it was split into like three or
four hour chunks but you people do stop
intermittently on their own accord
because you do the shops
yeah well there's a there's a there's a
there's a pret there's a pret down there
so you can uh yeah you can get an Auntie
Anne's like a white yeah there's a
pretzel someone on the way down they
close down the Jamba Juice bastards yeah
where does he call it yeah well no I
think the natives didn't like it what
about like a boutique like a mom and pop
store like us there's a couple of
vintage shops yeah there's a vintage
shop where you can buy old band T-shirts
um you people stop intermittently on
their own accord because I'm telling you
dude I was a fit college kid and working
out all the time is skinny and fit as
I've ever been playing basketball every
day running and lifting I multiple times
was like damn I gotta chill first plus
it's like 120 degrees right is it cool
it down down mile down of course it gets
cooler but you wouldn't go when it's
that hot they wouldn't let you go I
don't think they I don't think they do
it all year round they only do it
certain times of the year because it's
dangerous when the heat is too high and
then is it freezing at night right
because it's not freezing but it's cold
right it's cold you're wearing sweaters
and a jacket speaking of that speaking
of being down below so that's six
thousand feet deep that's mind-blowing
this Titanic vessel that Explorer thing
that you have to pay 25 000 250 000 I
think it sank a different way now so no
well now what this is 12 500 feet deep
below the ocean floor they have today
this one comes out two days but as of
today they have about 10 hours of oxygen
left but the rescue mission even if they
found them would take 20 hours to do
what he's talking about right now they
went missing is someone missing right
now here let me explain so the Titanic
there's a submarine that you can take
that goes and you can explore the
Titanic the wreckage of the Titanic 900
miles off the coast of Nova Scotia 250
000 a person it's the same people that
went on this are some of the same people
that went into space on that blue origin
thing whatever okay so this submarine
lost contact with the you know boat at
the surface a few hours after it started
to submerge and it's been missing for
the past two days and it only has 72
hours worth of oxygen or 72 to 90 hours
worth of oxygen on board so that the
scenarios are they're not going to find
them and they're going to suffocate
they've already floated to the top of
the ocean somewhere and the ocean is so
vast that they don't know where they are
and they're trying to look for the them
how does not have Radars on them 150
000 a person for the well the third the
third one nobody threw an air tag inside
of there I know I just tossed an air
attack well the conspiracy is that one
of the guys in there is one of the
wealthiest men in Pakistan is one of the
guys who is the leading researchers on
alien outer space Technologies the
conspiracy is this is on purpose and
they wanted him to go right because they
can't find it at all and they said that
what most likely I heard on on the news
this morning the one guy said the most
likely scenario right now is that
something they went got down below to
where they're supposed to be and there
was a microscopic crack in the
foundation of it and if that even the
most microscopic crack because of the
pressure they died their bodies crushed
instantly and there's no you'll never
find them they've now been crushed and
like into the bottom of the ocean floor
which you'll never find what are we
hoping was the scenario I guess the
crushing if that you don't want to die
yeah because they're stuck in there the
only way to open this container is with
a drill from the outside you cannot open
it from the inside so they'll suffocate
to God so think about they're in a tomb
think about their fate right now if
they're still in there and they're just
going to run out of oxygen well I think
about it like this actually I know that
sound this sounds I mean so you're
saying that the the submarine died it
has the power or it got stuck on the
Titanic like hooked by accident no
you're saying that that's one of the
series you're saying that's one of the
theories and you know how can't they go
down there with another one no because
there's only 20 hours a thousand twelve
thousand five hundred feet to get down
it's too much else you can't you can't
do it you can't you got to do it at very
slow speed you have to do a slow speed
because the the crushing pressure yeah
but if you're in the if you're in the
submarine in there it's all pressurized
no but they're saying no no what they're
saying is the the dissension has to be
slow slowly timed in order for it to
continue to adjust right so the machine
as it goes down is adjusting to the
pressure itself because if it doesn't it
gets crushed huh it's all of our
technology it still takes that long yeah
because we're down two miles we're not
supposed to be down that far yeah yeah
and you know what God wanted us not down
there yeah God said don't go down there
they didn't believe in us God did God
did let's go golfing yes let's go golf
hole in one let's Golf
and I I hope that they got crushed
because if there was like lesson like
imagine like just clip that well imagine
I hope that I hope they got crushed you
don't want to say that you hope they
died peacefully you know but because
think about how embarrassing that would
be if you're running out of oxygen and
as the oxygen like you're just coming
left and right because so like you know
the autoerotic asphyxiation thing and
you're just coming coming all over that
[__] submarine good angle yeah I
wouldn't like that good angle I like
this yeah the part that made me think
about Sal in the situation is that the
bathroom on board is a couple of Ziploc
bags like on a seat Contraption no for
250 000 for 250 dollars you [__] into a
Ziploc that's what my stepson does every
day
that is grim dude imagine being like
look we lost contact if they don't find
us in 10 hours we're gonna watch each
other suffocate
killing everybody though because what
happens is when they run out of oxygen
they'll they'll fall asleep from the
carbon they won't realize that I mean oh
they'll know they're gonna go but those
yeah the CO2 will just take them first
so it'll genuinely peaceful yeah it is
kind of you actually will slowly just go
to bed I mean you won't be gasping no at
a certain point you'll just be breathing
in the scene you'll be breathing in CO2
and then you'll slowly go I mean do you
know the story of Payne Stewart do you
know this you ever heard this there's an
old story but
he was a famous golfer he was taking a
private jet from Florida to his home in
Texas after a tournament and this is an
insane this is an insane story this is
uh what year was Payne Stewart's death
no he put in pain saturated story
yeah and don't say it out loud too loud
so this is one of the saddest stories in
the history show images of the plane so
he was on a private jet with like his
business manager his partner and a few
other people blah blah he's supposed to
go from Florida to Dallas and this is
awful oh the plane the plane lost oxygen
right and they froze to death and they
froze in the plane and so there was a
call because the air control couldn't
get a hold of them so they sent up
fighter jets to fly next to it because
then you're in Aerospace now you're in
now you're a threat to Aerospace so the
military sends up just to see what's
going on in this flight and they full up
next to them and the pilots of the of
the military can see no it's on
autopilot a fog and they're frozen to
death they're frozen still and they're
playing this flying
I can't how is this not a movie well I
think they've probably tried a few times
it's the tragic the the hardest part was
so it's going from Florida over the gulf
to to Dallas I think and then when what
happened was is they had a discussion
with like you know the Pentagon in the
military had to call about where are
they going to shoot this plane down or
how you know so they did the
calculations of how much gas they had
left of where it would naturally crash
so because they have to do that for you
know human safety they were trying to
figure out how should they divert this
to crash in a way without without
shooting it down but naturally let it
crash or guide it to crash uh so it
doesn't hurt anybody and these they were
they were frozen to death on the plane
because of the crap what happened was
it's never heard it's a couple of
theories I think you can look it up but
it says either
um they lost cabin pressure and the
oxygen was gone so because of altitude
they froze to death and the plane so
instantly freeze to death yeah you do
it's pretty quick they've crashed into a
cow yeah they after all that they
crashed into a county or a pasture near
Mina four hours left of after Orlando
yeah 1400 miles across the country on
autopilot before I ran out of fuel so
what they did was they were debating
whether they're going to shoot it out of
the sky and they thought it was
unethical to shoot it down because they
were like who knows if they're still
alive you they can't find out if someone
might be still alive they assumed of
course you know doctors are they were
like there's literally no chance they
could be alive it's impossible but they
were like well let's just not shoot it
down just in the event that we're
killing them if they're really alive so
they they flew next to this thing until
it slowly ran out of fuel and then
Kareem down and floated down and they
were hoping you know planes just don't
nosedive after it runs out what will
happen they'll just float and guide
right the engines will slowly spin out
right and then it slowly spun out and
then crash obviously no one's survived
anyway but oh my God they followed it
till it crash how crazy is that oh wow
and they just just by The Stroke of Luck
it crashed in a field well in a sub city
no what they did was they did the timing
of when they were going to run out of
fuel and they said if it stayed on the
flight path they found out it would have
crashed within this 10 mile radius so
they feel comfortable it was never going
to be near a big city so they were like
well we'll just if it was going to go
near a city they would have had to
physically use the planes to diverge it
to somewhere else like bump into it to
change directions yeah it physically
change directions yeah you gotta wait
for a gate
well then the bags and but by the way
the bags
where are my bags yeah we lost their
bags it's crazy that is that's crazy
that's horrific that's one of the
craziest stories you ever feel like
flying private I don't think I don't
ever do it so no I I don't ever do it
for it's like a thing I never amounted
enough because that I've done it it's
gonna happen on a commercial airline
almost never it will never happen on a
commercial what is the reason why it
happens I have backup systems and backup
systems for their backup private plane
is like literally on some guy's plane
commercial airlines are so unbelievably
safe when you research them it's CR it
is crazy they've taken so much
precautionary measure on top of
precautionary measure Netflix
to my buddies did this
guys back home yeah it's haunting the
pilot they think flew up as high as he
could go and knocked everybody out right
yeah he did no no no no no no did you
watch all four episodes maybe I didn't
then that was the initial they were
blaming the pilot initially but then
there was like another theory then
another theory then another theory and I
was I got up to the last episode I don't
know where they left off they we still
don't know what happened I know but you
know this was something something was
afoot this did this was not natural in
fact no United States commercial
airlines has ever had an incident even
close to this at all yeah ours have
always been it was mechanical and they
never found it right they never ever
they found debris they found pieces of
it so they think what do you think the
theory is what is the theory then Andrew
what happened tell us what happened
someone was on that plane that needed to
go away and somebody made it happen no
100 and so you think everyone died
because of one person oh who why would
they care for Colombia yeah that's not a
big deal when it when it comes to
International Terror they don't take
into account other lives but why
wouldn't that come out in the wash
somebody the person that they were
that's like saying how come we don't
know how many people the cartel have
killed it's like this is this is nothing
to them yeah why is it they're doing it
all day every day but what about the
fact that show me Hunter Biden's laptop
I believe the Malaysian airlines
not going to jail he's got he's on
pictures with guns hookers selling drugs
not going to jail no dude it's like
what's the reason you're thinking like
an American truly like an American we we
we know we know how to get you we know
we know how to get you dude
internationally these people get away
with stuff all the time I just don't
know how we haven't solved it also
because I want to be sorry
goodbye I don't think the US government
invests any time
they say they do and then they're like I
think they're going to give us an
interest in them not solving it yeah did
you see the footage don't poke your nose
bleeding waiting around to find out that
it was that was that was I watched that
before I don't watch that on the I
watched that on the road in in uh
Niagara Falls whoa before I went on
stage I just remember it because I can't
decide to Canada side yes first time I
saw it and I was so [__] depressed
and then I went on stage at that and I
came back and then finished it and I
just remember now I associate those
beautiful Falls with the Malaysian
Airlines maybe that's where the plane is
bad it is I hated Niagara Falls no what
do we think are they let me down so much
it let me down yeah all you see is
casinos and hotels shitty hotels and
casinos it's not a the neighborhood
itself it needs work it's bad yeah yeah
fix the dark side is bad the Canada side
is good no not the side was nothing the
New York side is the worst part no
they're both bad no but you tell me
about the view of the thing itself yeah
or something like that
um what uh so what do you think do you
think you're gonna find this Titanic
vessel you think it's not happening
they're gone you think they're dead
forever we're never gonna find them
nothing well no because we can't go down
12 000 feet to go look for them why are
people doing this
are so bored they've done all the stuff
and this is a thing it's access you
can't do this this is like you know he's
in for this yeah but there is because
you because most people can't do it they
just want a thing that no one can do
it's like it's Instagram [__] yeah
that's exactly right Dove to the bottom
it's how deep does your day go yeah the
Titanic going down with the Titanic Oh
there's it's like being in the Soho
House only a few by the way doesn't that
that looks like a flashlight
that's why it's lost like we've been
put him in the flash out of existence
what's happening
and the craziest thing is one of the
owners of the company was the captain
really
shady
if you can't check for a hairline a
fracture small fracture in the thing how
would you ever go down there if one
fracture one tiny fraction I'd be too
nervous man it's not worth it a couple
experts went on TV about this exact
piece yeah and they said that most the
um building materials from Like Home
Depot and there was only one part built
by NASA no way
they said the Home Depot stuff was not
important
it was interested
if I was if I if I was lows
right now
the new logo the new logo is like the
Home Depot on that thing going down
they said most likely they lost their
light system so it's pitch dark oh yeah
that's insane that's the scariest thing
so so now so it can be alive right now
talking right now highly doubt it well
the one scenario I heard is is is the
most likely is that it's been crushed
like Andrew said and it's done but there
is one scenario that I didn't know about
the lights but there's one scenario
where they're just floating towards the
bottom of the ocean still with enough
oxygen but this vessel cannot go up on
its own some there's something that it
can't do on its own right it can't do
everything on its own no you're if
you're going down there it's 18 years
old it's got to be out in the real world
yeah get a job figure it out yeah it's
not our problem too worried about
getting a sex change
you know these vessels are taking
hormone blockers now
it had systems in place to rise up they
failed but even if they did rise up and
they're floating somewhere in the ocean
they cannot open the vessel they can't
open it and we don't have some type of
again wow a a radar we cannot track this
thing they can't I think it's two it
goes down too far sonar can't go there
within an hour and 40 minutes they lost
contact in an hour and 40 minutes maybe
it was a suicide mission maybe they were
down to get down I can't deal with this
you know I heard there are a couple of
cracks they fixed them with Flex Seal
Flex Seal
if they only would have had it it'd be
funny if they're having a party down
there like like live looking it's just
they got music on like who [__] oh
yeah
the internet is saying it's aliens
because of the Whistleblower guys that
the government wanted them gone either
they wanted them gone or they made
contact by accident because now UFOs can
go underwater apparently
that's what they live now just recently
yeah they didn't want to do it for years
Jesus Christ they just got over it
Russell Simmons deeply sorry for
screaming at his daughters downplays
allegations what did he scream that he
had to say he's not allowed to yell at
your own kids anymore yeah why was he
deeply started an article to pick up he
didn't even he didn't like hit anybody
you're allowed to yell as loud as you
want oh yeah my kids with Cricket sticks
downplays abuse can we hear audio
and then the video you know this who is
this the post they're never gonna play a
real video it's always it could be six
different ads for another video that
they don't show
Russell Simmons daughters with Kimora
Lee rip into him on Father's Day
oh this is clickbait for Father's Day
this is nonsense
no that's him what is it that is him
let's hear it why is he screaming into
the
um
that's fine
he looks like an angry bull man
how do they do that a little careful
real close real close yeah how did they
do um I Heard a yeah I heard ABM I heard
that's all I heard he looks like an
angry an angry bold man I heard it b-l-a
I heard it bla blad man yeah
um I'm a bad man oh this is over she she
screened recorded a FaceTime is that
what happened oh no no no no no no no no
when you screen record Facetime the
audio doesn't show up I've tried to do
this with friends like recording like us
well now it does I heard now you can I
don't think so because I just did try to
recently and it Well audio won't come we
can we were FaceTiming with my dad and
he was drunk and my sister was trying to
get it and it and we got no audio I
think that's what happens it takes away
the audio when you FaceTime this is all
[__] up you wanna you wanna uh
um do the words for him all the yells
like you could be the words of what he's
saying okay all right well get your edit
finger ready
really you really think that those
[__] are alive at the bottom of
the ocean you dumb [__]
I sent your ass to private school all
these years and you out here saying is
aliens you're a dumb [__]
I'm telling you I'm telling you but Dad
but but Dad you know what this really is
I've given you everything I've done
everything for you the fact that you
would say that to me or do that I can
see in his face he's doing that I've
done everything for you've been given
everything this is the problem with
celebrity kids like the Baldwin yeah
they're giving too much they're giving
too much yeah
yeah
right when he's giving you're talking
about when they recorded him all blacked
out drunk on the floor oh is that what
you're talking about oh uh no that's
Hasselhoff oh Hasselhoff that's right
didn't Alec Baldwin be like call his
daughter a pig and she sent the voice
yeah yeah and they send it to somebody
no when Hasselhoff was drunk on the
floor and they made him feel embarrassed
about partying in his own home was they
kind of pissed me off
he was blacked out eating a cheeseburger
and his kids were like you're
embarrassing he's like I'm in the
comfort of my own home blacked out in a
cheese if you can't do that I don't know
what it what what America am I
randomly ran out of the ocean by the way
a bear run out of the ocean anytime we
bleep our curses you should just put in
rocket money
[Laughter]
what the rocket money yeah that bear
they say was down there with that vessel
yeah the only one that came back that
was it was that that's the cocaine bear
who did the uh
the wall with the four presidents on at
the mountain Rushmore who did it how did
they do it Dynamite
dynamite and then hand carved yeah how
do you hand carve a mountain
it chisel away slowly but sure and the
guy died in the middle of it it's still
not done I think multiple people died
and there was a Native American leader
too on the other side that's half done
that's right yeah do you see that one as
well is it right there yeah yeah who
chose the four the guy no the people
they did a vote no it was a vote it was
a country ride vote it was yeah the
country voted oh I'm I know I know
little to nothing about our forefathers
buddy yeah four fathers why we say our
forefathers our forefathers yeah but
those are not the first four they're
just the four weeks how funny so someone
there was an online poll yeah it was on
the internet how did everyone vote they
mailed it in no come on I swear it's
true Pony Express no it's real pony
expressed it in Carmen Isaiah Doan
Robinson
um South Dakota blah blah they picked up
they picked those ones via vote and they
said that how funny Would it be by the
way if they wanted to add a fifth
president and they did it again and
Trump won could you imagine Trump's face
was on Mount Rushmore yeah
but he'd have to write something like
gay or something gay wow that's wild
South Dakota how do they uh maintain it
how do they assure that uh erosion
erosion doesn't get to it I think
they've I think it says in there first I
think I've heard that they've sealed
yeah yeah they Flex sealed it it is it
is that's his name sculptler goosan
gutsan Borglum design the sculpture
Europeans are just better
yeah the rate of erosion on the granite
faces
is 70 uh the rate of the road of granite
phase is estimated at one tenth of an
inch per 1000 years so it ain't
happening oh it didn't happen one tenth
of an inch per one but eventually it's
gonna happen no
no eventually if they're building the
Earth is not going to last that long ten
thousand years for that to erode one
inch ten thousand years it's never to
erode one inch okay so if we're around
another billion okay
let me tell you idiot guy Wishful tea
here we go let me tell you something
humans are gone in the next 50 years I
think we're out of here real soon
I think we're gone soon soak it up
though that's why you go to Montauk ten
thousand years you're seeing me like
this what I look like today this is what
I walk around thinking about I mean I
think about it all the time let's think
about it but that's why I do fun things
because I'm like whatever that's right I
can see my friends because I think oh
should I stop by New York or should I go
back and do other work no why don't I go
see my friends do some spots have some
fun because we're gone I mean it we're
gone and I'm okay with thinking
yeah I can't
yeah
40 years or the problem and the solution
in my opinion I think we cost the
solution will be taking care of us and
getting us gone oh I like it are you
giving me us hope now hope no hope
there's a dark side of hope there is no
hope here but the hopelessness is kind
of beautiful it's over it's like uh Let
It Go no it's not it's like optimistic
uh
optimistic one day you'll all be gone
that's okay live life to the fullest hey
that's pessimistic Prime
oh
pessimistic crime
yeah
we're all going to die
the ice cream machine is never working
at McDonald's this glass is half empty
pessimistic Prime
by the way this is what we should name
this episode The Shrine of hypocrisy
I honestly think that I'm going to have
a panic attacker why because he told me
that we're gonna we are going to witness
the end yes but just like the people in
the submarine you're just gonna fall
asleep you're not even gonna know about
it and you're gonna be laughing now oh
you dancing real
a global thing where the [__] hits the
fan everyone plays that song and so it's
just like something to hold on to and we
all and we all jump at the same time you
know they tried that in the 80s you know
they tried that to everyone to jump at
the same time in the United States yeah
look it up across America no no they try
to have everyone jump at the exact same
time look it up how many people did it
48 52 maybe I often asked the the
balcony of the mezzanine of a theater to
all get up and jump to test the
soundness yeah but like what they say
the people on the opposite uh world
would cancel cancel each other out
nothing would happen yeah it'd be so
stupid nothing would ever happen all
right let's just say everybody on one
half of the earth jumped
doesn't matter right so why do they do
that why do they try to do it yeah they
thought it was going to create some sort
of effect I think people got bored in
the 80s like real real bored well you're
making so much money with cocaine and
money and you're like and some coke guy
right downtown here was like What if we
I would have had everybody jump
and sometimes let's do it do it tell
everyone you know
it's a pre-internet so you just have to
keep telling people on Coke every Coke
bathroom
everyone's jumping you know everyone's
jumping in February
you know they had a problem yeah
um yeah Y2K was a big [__] thing
wasn't it no ah I think it really was a
thing nothing happened it's like nothing
happened that you know something went
down something there was a shift there
was like a paradigm shift in our brains
or something I think I think the
computers didn't reset to zero but they
initiated something else and that what
would that what is the prediction I
think that was a tick tock clock baby to
the aliens being like it's come get us
it's ready we're time let's you really
genuinely aren't believing you today yes
I believe I believe it's we're ready to
rock pimp knows what the [__] I'm
talking about take this off the goddess
what do you think happened a year later
what happened one year later one year
later oh you think you think 911 had
nothing to do with Y2K I never give me a
break really you think that was just a
weird coincidence then after the turning
point of technology and time that they
thought that the government itself was
like things might get bad and then they
got bad come on dude give me a break
what are you talking about this has been
hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe
[Music]